[Música]
[Aplausos]
uma vez um quilombo
hoje vou contar pra vocês uma história
sobre hipóteses bonecas e mulheres
eu vou começar por essa aqui que você
fala
desde criança fui muito estimulada foi
uma criança que aprende a mexer com as
mãos
minha mãe me deu a capacidade de
imaginar os livros meu pai me deu as
ferramentas alicates martelos me colocou
no alto da escada para aprender a mexer
na fiação elétrica
meus avós me ensinaram a costurar a
abordar a fazer roupa da boneca com isso
gente eu tive sempre a possibilidade de
fazer a possibilidade a possibilidade de
criar e isso me moveu isso me moveu na
minha curiosidade as mãos curiosas
sempre me levaram a esse pensamento que
eu poderia realizar e isso me moveu na
minha vida profissional eu fui fazer a
universidade o curso de design e isso é
me levou a aprofundar essa relação com
os materiais as disciplinas preferidas
eram oficina de madeira oficina de metal
a representação gráfica com o pastel com
lápis de cor tudo isso é me aproximava
essa capacidade de representação eu
nunca foi exímia desenhista
mas eu nunca me impossibilitou a
representação do outro e foi isso que me
moveu durante a minha o meu percurso
profissional e nas minhas escolhas de
vida também
quando eu tinha 23 anos recém-formada eu
vim pro maranhão nem de férias com as
minhas amigas e aqui decidi que ia ficar
escolhi são luís para a minha casa de lá
pra cá foram 14 anos
nessas escolhas que a gente faz na vida
a gente sempre paga um preço né as
pessoas ficavam um pouco assustadas vai
sair do rio de janeiro para o maranhão
ea mãe ficou um ano sem falar comigo
achando que eu estava dando um tiro no
pé
mas hoje ela reconhece você atirou no
que viu acertou
que não viu e assim eu comecei a minha
carreira né profissional em são luís e
já chegando aqui na cidade eu comecei a
fazer mestrado em ciências sociais em
deparei com esse livro
ele foi fundador pra mim pro meu
pensamento sobre o que eu queria para a
minha vida eu não queria ficar sentada
atrás de um computador
eu não queria a a vida mediada né pelas
máquinas eu queria conhecer pessoas eu
queria é representar o outro de uma
forma muito próxima
então essa idéia do trabalho do designer
como atrás do computador
isso foi deixado de lado na minha vida
então esse livro que eu não sou
sociólogo norte-americano chamado ser
laico news
ele fala sobre isso sobre a vida do
pesquisador como artesanato e
coincidência ou não era justamente o que
eu pesquisava produção artesanal
então eu vou montando essa apresentação
eu comecei a procurar fotos que eu
queria fazer um contraponto entre raquel
trabalhando no computador e raquel em
campo e eu não encontrei nem freud
explica foto nenhuma minha trás do
computador só me encontrei assim
pintando com as artesãs com a mão na
massa
[Música]
leando conversando e é isso que eu
queria para minha vida e é isso que eu
consegui construir nesse percurso até
que eu cheguei em alcântara alcântara na
verdade como campo de pesquisa ao cantar
eu cheguei desde o início quando eu
cheguei aqui em são luís é por um lugar
muito especial pra mim essa questão do
tempo eu não queria perder tempo atrás
em trânsito não é isso que me moveu do
rio de janeiro para a calma
dentre outras coisas e apesar de hoje
são luís está desse jeito também e estar
em alcântara me permitiu isso né se
perceber esse acúmulo do tempo o acúmulo
das imagens das mensagens é de toda a
questão das lendas das histórias e das
ruínas o que significam essas ruínas
essas ruínas para mim elas são a
história que fica escondida a história
não contada e foi atrás
história essa história não contada que
eu me lancei a pesquisar os quilombos de
alcântara alcântara não é só o centro
histórico de alcântara né
existem vários povoados praias lindas e
muitas histórias que a gente né tá estão
disponíveis para a gente conhecer
dentre os povoados eu conheci um muito
especial chamado itamatatiua itapé drama
tamata peixe tio a rio ita patativa é um
lugar com uma territorialidade muito
específica foi formada por negros
fugidos de todos os ingênuos nessas
fazendas de alcântara e lá foram
acobertados pelos frades carmelitas né
que deram todo o apoio para que se esses
negros se estabelecesse nesse povoado lá
formaram famílias reproduziram suas
famílias e levaram consigo a imagem de
santa teresa d'ávila lá de alcântara e
santa teresa passa a ser às donas deste
território então além de ser terra de
treta alcântara e está na ativa também é
terra de santa de santa teresa
santa teresa é a protetora a fundadora e
acolhe a todas as famílias que lá moram
num itamatatiua as mulheres fazem pots
otis como esse
esses pacotes já movimentavam toda a
economia do lugar
e fazem isso há mais de 300 anos desde
que lá chegaram nesse momento é a
produção do pote vem decaindo nesta toda
a modificação da paisagem econômica
social e cultural vem modificando a
produção de tratativa
antigamente as minhas informantes contam
que elas faziam 20 potes por dia e
colocava no forno mais de 300 de uma vez
nesse processo toda a comunidade
se sustentável da produção da cerâmica
as mulheres faziam nos quintais com seus
filhos do lado e os homens vendiam
colocavam nos caminhões e um vender por
toda a baixada maranhense e isso
movimentará a economia fazer um pote não
é um
um trabalho muito fácil ele nasce uma
bolinha e ele vai sendo levantado as
mulheres vão rodando e levantando o pote
modelam o bojo sempre nessa posição
observe a senhora aí é dona neide dona
neide tem 67 anos
vocês conhecem na cidade grande alguma
mulher quase 70 anos sentado assim e
assim trabalhando fazer um pote como eu
disse é um ritual
elas dão o bojo fazem o pescoço dele
nenhuma boca
muitas vezes o pacote também tem orelhas
nessa relação à mulher abraça o pote
para moldá lo
o corpo das mulheres é moldado pelo
barro assim como barra moldado pelas
mulheres nessa relação corporal
cosmológica mulher hipóteses são da
mesma matéria quando elas querem falar
sobre a produção da cerâmica em
tratativa a gente pergunta como é que o
cerâmica aceleração da minha gente e
negrinha que nem nós nesse processo de
auto identificação com o próprio
trabalho
eu também me identifico com elas nesse
processo de construção mútua de que o
que a gente faz o nosso trabalho é a
nossa identidade e como as pessoas não
percebem a partir dessa identidade
qual é a imagem que construímos a partir
da nossa pesquisa que não é só trabalho
é também uma forma de viver itamatatiua
essa cosmologia também está muito
presente é muito preponderante
essa imagem é o oposto do chora posto do
shopping é um lugar encantado é um lugar
que é aguardado por uma sapa dourada e
uma serpente
enquanto a gente busca toda a mitologia
sobre a produção da cerâmica a gente
encontra na mitologia ameríndia é de
todos os povos indígenas que há o bairro
onde é feita a cerâmica é o mais
profundo do barreiro
e lá ele é guardado por serpentes
nessa relação cosmológica em vários
tipos de interdições mulher não pode
tocar em barro quando está menstruada
o ciclo menstrual ele afeta a textura do
barro e quando a gente coloca o bairro
traçar ele pode rachar a outra coisa é a
questão do ciclo lunar também não pode
colocar o bote pra trás a quando a lua
cheia outra no quarto crescente porque a
força da lua faz com que a louça spot e
nesse contexto é essa a gente acaba se
envolvendo é o trabalho ea vida eu
também me deixei levar por essas
histórias de serpente está mais ativa
ainda no primeiro momento de
levantamento né estava visitando vários
povoados e fui mordido por uma cobra e
foi uma confusão com medo eu chorando
tava longe de alcântara não tinha soro
foi para são luís fica em alcântara eu
sei que no meio da confusão uma
senhorinha lado o povoado onde eu estava
me falou assim as filhas eram vai morrer
não a senhora vai lembrar toda vez que
virá a lua toda vez que fizer
aniversário a senhora lembra da cobra
mas não vai morrer não na hora que eu
não me causou um impacto estava muito
nervosa mas depois eu percebi que aquilo
ali é realmente era um aviso né e frisou
voltei pra casa ficou tudo bem
cicatrizou a a mordida e mas é
impressionante dava um mês quando
chegava na mesma lua daquele período no
qual tínhamos sido mordida e aferida
brilha e eu passei uns seis sete meses
nesse processo de abrir ferida fechar a
ferida
então eu percebi o que era temporalidade
o que era estar ligado ao território
[Música]
e nesse processo chega o desenvolvimento
em tratativa a partir da década de 70 e
80 os potes não não eram mais produzidos
ou muito pouco já não tinha aquela
quantidade sendo vendida por que chegou
o plástico o plástico e água encanada
conversando com dona maria que tem 85
anos dona maria me contando sobre
produção sobre o passado da produção e
eu perguntei para ela dona maria senhora
não tem nenhum pacote em casa
ela tem uns têm uma sentinela mandou
neto buscar quando ela trouxe ela botou
pote molhado que estava dentro de um de
um tanque e começou continuou falando e
eu vislumbrei essa imagem que eu
fotografei né que representa exatamente
isso né esse pote de um lado ea
geladeira de outro representando essa
chegada do desenvolvimento a chegada do
progresso
a luz elétrica afastou as mães d'água
por outro lado água encanada
a partir de 1988 principalmente com
direitos coletivos das comunidades
quilombolas é começar a chegar
pesquisadores as próprias políticas
públicas mede reconhecimento saúde e
educação então todo o lado bom do
desenvolvimento também chegou em
tratativa e o que me interessa nessa
história toda a chegada dos turistas que
no seu bojo trouxe-as consultoria de
design
essa relação entre design e artesanato é
muito pesquisada tanto no campo do
design quanto no campo da antropologia e
eu não vou me deter
nela neste momento mas é muito
importante a gente pensar que é uma
relação delicada um designer que chega
com conhecimento de fora eo artesão que
está na comunidade todo o detentor de um
saber ligado àquele território e como se
dá essa relação como se dá essa relação
de construção mútua de construção e
respeito ao saber né de cada um
e aí numa dessas consultorias lá pelos
idos de 2000 foi implantada um plano
implantado um novo produto que foi a
boneca do quilombo a boneca representa
um produto muito menor se a gente pega
uma boneca
a boneca dá pra gente levar pra casa dá
para botar na mala e levar como souvenir
não dá pra gente levar um pote de
lembrancinha do quilombo e toda essa
busca pelo quilombo fala disso a gente
levar para casa um outro tempo uma outra
vivência uma outra forma de vivenciar as
relações da natura
e é por isso que os turistas buscam um
quilombo e nesse processo as artesãs
começar a modelar suas antepassadas tem
várias histórias né a chica pimenta que
essa daqui e começaram a embalar esses
produtos para viagem uma das demandas
das artesãs era que se construísse uma
caixa para que as bonecas pudessem ser
transportadas sem quebrar e isso
facilitaria a venda hoje uma boneca
custa mais caro do que um pote e é um
produto muito mais vendável
nesse sentido e que mulher é essa
representada nas bonecas assunto e
passadas as mulheres bucho duas com
feixe de lenha na cabeça com o pote na
cabeça
amo essa daqui no primeiro plano é neusa
que ela costumava modelar a cerâmica e
amamentar o mesmo tempo então ela ela
ficava com os seios de fora amamentando
e cuidando dos filhos
e são essas bonecas que eram levadas
instigado com isso
durante a nossa pesquisa é um dos alunos
meus queria modelar
ele queria representar as artesãs e aí a
gente propôs uma oficina na oficina de
bonecas
nessa oficina é a gente propôs que cada
uma modelar se a outra e o resultado
disso é incrível e aí eu faço uma
pequena pausa para fazer uma nova
reflexão sobre esse processo de
identificação de como o turista esse
processo da fotografia da construção da
imagem não é de quem vem de fora desse
quilombo como isso constrói a identidade
das artesãs como elas contam histórias
que falam desse processo de aproximação
com o turista principalmente então o
discurso que elas constroem para mim é
moldado pelo que elas acham que eu
gostaria de escutar e isso é imaginário
coletivo do quilombo é essa a imagem que
o bola que é o que eu discuti tanto na
minha tese quanto um documentário que lá
nós realizamos intitulado a mão e fogo
e essa imagem é muito interessante
porque não
filme isso é uma cena e ela tá olhando
para a foto o tempo todo ela tá depois
olhando para minha câmera ela está
dialogando tanto com a turista quanto
comigo
isso é muito interessante de de perceber
e essa foi a oficina de bonecas em que
cada uma modelo a outra e aí o resultado
foi incrível e foi muito emocionante de
perceber como elas gostariam de ser
identificadas que mulheres eram essas as
bonecas do quilombo
essa daí a ângela ângela não tá com
fecho de lenha na cabeça relata de
óculos
ângela sabe ler e escrever e é
responsável por toda a contabilidade da
loja ela que faz a toda aa a aa as
contas e faz a distribuição neto dos
lucros entre as artesãs
essa daqui a duca nunca é uma das
artistas mais jovens que adora passear
toda hora tá pegando ferry boat para ir
para são luís
então dunga tá sempre de bolsa
são imagens de poder amento são imagens
que falam sobre quem essas mulheres
querem ser identidade é essa que nós
podemos construir juntas como mulher
como pesquisadora com uma artesã e esse
último caso é para mim o mais
emblemático
durante esse processo da pesquisa no
quilombo elas pediram para os meus
alunos desenhar os jogadores de futebol
era a época da copa do mundo que elas
queriam fazer uma linha de produtos para
a copa
visando uma venda maior visando o
mercado
e aí os meninos desenharam os
bonequinhos e elas fizeram juntos lá
recortar uma plaquinha e elas aplicaram
numa bíblia como essa
e essa bíblia eu fiquei em título e com
uma bíblia da copa a gente pode fazer
todas as ressalvas
não é um produto lindo esteticamente mas
é um produto feito idealizado e
solicitado a nós designers por elas
artesãs e é nesse processo de auto
identificação de reconhecimento que a
gente constrói a nossa identidade como
pesquisadores e elas como artesãs
e tem uma frase no quilombo que eu me
identifico muito que fala de si
empoderamento e é com essa frase que eu
vou me despedindo de vocês que é quem
não pode com o pote não coloca rodilha
obrigado
[Música]